valentine's day is one week from today
and cassie beach house located at the
all new virgin hotel has a special for
you and your boo here to tell us all
about it you like you like that right
you do that this is chef josh stockton
good to see you buddy good happy year
and thanks for having me how would you
describe the restaurant in three words
coastal beach italian i love it it's
good short the short descriptions are
not my thing but you know that one right
there i'll take it so what do you guys
have planned for for valentine's day so
we have a four course tasting menu we've
got some oysters and caviar some crudo
that i brought for you to try and then
some of our wagyu meatballs okay what
are they this is uh so what we have here
so this is two of our crudos salmon
crudo and hamachi crudo then we're gonna
have wagyu meatballs with mint caper
salsa whoa um entree course you're going
to get veal meal and ace also going to
get a truffle tagly towel that sounds
good and then tiramisu for dessert okay
you want me to try something you said
i want you to have everything that
sounds good to me well you i need i need
something to drink first before we try
the food i know you have a special
cocktail set up for valentine's day what
is it we do so this is our valentine's
day cocktail uh it's hennessy some
homemade raspberry preserves a little
simple syrup some lemon juice
and some egg whites so shaking you get
that nice little froth on top and we're
going to make it together we're shaking
this during the commercial what's the
actual name of the cocktail
just the valentine's day one is that the
uh the the cassie the coffee kiss kiss
could be well that sounds good right so
this is already shaken so support why
why do we have a strainer because we got
the ice in there and you got the
raspberries preserved in there so you
don't want to get those chunks inside
okay nice and what's the alcohol in here
uh hennessy
this is imagine you and your lover on
valentine's day having this delicious
delicious drink candlelight dinner yes
are you getting candies first no okay
now which goes on top of this so we have
some um
chocolate bitters so we'll do a couple
drops on here
you go are you trying to make something
right now with you doing a design like a
starbucks barista on top of my car
bartenders are much better at this but
they're gonna actually drop them in
there the master i am not a cocktail i
keep telling the the [ __ ]
i was going to you should see me try to
make lattes at the house too it's not my
uh strong suit all this stuff i can do
yeah the bartenders we have much better
than me well the drink looks delicious
the food looks amazing now our
reservations available because a lot of
people watching right now they are
valentine's day is a week away do you
have reservations available we do we're
actually we're very busy on monday right
now we have um some early and late but
we also doing this special all weekend
so you can come in friday saturday or
sunday night to get it because the big
game is on sunday so take your date out
on you know if you go out on saturday
night and watch the game is hanging out
you're such a smart man i love it four
years marriage it's good okay can i try
the dessert you go right ahead and
what's the dessert that's a tiramisu
tiramisu you guys make this yourself and
how you do
what's inside this
traditional you have your mars capone
your ladyfingers homemade espresso
oh wow
that's good
i like it it's a little more a little
more balanced not the boozy that some
people do a little bit more on the
coffee that is smooth is what that is
now if i wanted to if my four course
dinner can i start with this course
number one you can go way you want i
love it chef how do people make
reservations so you can go on our social
media links there's a straight link to
go on to for valentine's day and you can
select the valentine's day menu so you
can go ahead and order that ahead of
time perfect we appreciate it thank you
so much